santé ou commerces un choix cornélien
pour l'union européenne surtout quand on
parle d'agriculture mais pourtant on
semble plus privilégié la manne
financière engrangés par l'exportation
plutôt que la bonne santé des
consommateurs comme d'habitude ce sont
les pesticides le centre du problème les
pesticides jugés trop dangereux pour
être autorisé dans l'union européenne
qui pourrait finalement être toléré la
raison épargné le commerce international
une décision qui résulte de plusieurs
années de lobbying des fabricants
ajoutez à ça des manoeuvres
diplomatiques d'un groupe d'une
quinzaine de pays etats unis et canada
en première ligne pour que bruxelles
cède du terrain dans sa propre
réglementation et ce rapport de l' ong
bruxelloise corporate europe observatory
publié ce lundi montre comment ces
pressions continuelles ont fait reculer
les responsables européens du simple
fonctionnaire au commissaire jusqu'à la
présidente de la commission européenne
ursula von der leyen a été fier
d'annoncer au monde un accord avec
donald trump à davos le mois dernier
nous avons eu de très bonnes discussions
le président américain et moi même ici à
davos et nous avons convenu que nous
voulions avancer rapidement
je pense que nous avons beaucoup en
commun beaucoup de choses sur lesquelles
il faut qu'on travaille
nous avons des problèmes à résoudre nous
ne devrions pas perdre trop de temps
mais s'asseoir et négocier immédiatement
et nous avons un processus de suivi dans
lequel on sera impliqué la législation
européenne bafouée pour pouvoir
favoriser les exportations étrangères et
ne pas contrarier l'oncle sam
voilà le topo pour aller plus en
profondeur du problème ces fameux
pesticides obéissent ou obéissait à des
critères d'exclusion précis dit
guillotine en d'autres termes une
interdiction automatique des pesticides
qui seront jugés intrinsèquement
dangereux
au moment de leur évaluation ou
réévaluation et ils sont plutôt nombreux
outre atlantique
un quart des pesticides employés aux
états unis plus précisément sont
interdits en europe
parmi eux le pesticides tueurs
d'abeilles
ce texte adopté en 2018 par les états
membres après des années de négociations
va donc être réévaluée au grand dam du
commissaire européen à la santé en
charge de ce dossier pour lequel
s'est longuement battu je suis heureux
que les états membres aient voté en
faveur de notre proposition d'aller plus
loin dans la restriction de
l'utilisation des substances actives
imidaclopride clothianidine et
thiaméthoxam connu sous le nom de
néonicotinoïdes les gouvernements ne
soient évidemment pas les seuls à mettre
la pression sur l'union européenne
depuis 2010 est les laboratoires
pharmaceutiques
un en particulier bayer n'hésite pas à
remettre en question toutes ces
interdictions et pour cela ils tentent
de faire jouer la corde sensible en
allant directement se plaindre auprès du
cabinet du commissaire à la santé
bayer s'inquiète du fait que cela
n'affecterait pas seulement ses
activités dans lieux mais aussi dans les
pays tiers s'exportant envers lieu le
cpa l'organisation européenne de
lobbying du secteur pharmaceutique est
aussi largement responsables de ce
soudain recul de nos européenne à
l'automne 2010 est un rapport avance que
les importations agricoles seraient
touchés à hauteur de 70 milliards
d'euros avec ces restrictions
alors que l'union européenne applique
les critères de coupure basée sur les
risques pour les substances actives
utilisées dans les produits de
protection des cultures la perte
éventuelle de limites maximales de
résidus de pesticides a le potentiel de
nuire aux importations agricoles évalue
à près de 70 milliards d'euros en 2016
au fil des trois dernières années toutes
ces pressions ont porté leurs fruits
c'est bien qu'en juillet 2019 l'union
européenne est accusé à travers un
rapport remis à l'om c'est par une
quinzaine de pays d'essayer d'imposer
unilatéralement sa propre approche
réglementaire intérieur à ses
partenaires commerciaux
fin de citation bruxelles semble donc
dans l'impasse et va très certainement
sacrifiés au nom du commerce sa lutte
contre les pesticides